How to
start a conversation in a business
meeting? This is a really good
question
to answer because otherwise we're going
to be twiddling our thumbs.
For this video, I want to do something
different. I actually want to share with
you
a virtual keynote that I gave at a big
global conference
called trend lab. And in this keynote. I
share
2 really mind-blowing stats. 3
specific tools that can help you have
better conversations in business
meetings and one story that will make
you cringe
a little bit. Enjoy the video. Without
further ado, let's
get into it.
Hey, everyone. Thank you, Sophie for the
introduction.
And trend miner for having me. You know,
we
show up to virtual conferences, summits,
events, in person summits, conferences,
events
for content. Right? We show up to get the
latest trends, the latest ideas
hear from experts in the field. And
oftentimes at the end of the conference,
the most impactful meaningful part
are the connections that we walk away
with. All the connections that happen in
between
the conference. And so, I'm really excited
to be in cyberspace with you today.
Trend Miner's done a phenomenal job
partnering with conversation starter
to create a platform for you to be
able to connect
rather than just consume information. So,
I'm Chad Littlefield. Before I tell you
anything that I know,
I would love to know what is something
you know
really well? Right? You know,
collectively, everybody watching this
right now is way smarter than just me.
And so, I want to know. What do you know?
And so, in the comments, feel free to
share what is something that you know
really well?
And one of the reasons that i wanted to
start off with this is
the first and primary reason I think
making digital connections is so
immensely valuable.
And that is this concept that everybody
you will ever meet knows something you
don't.
Everyone you'll ever meet knows
something you don't. And for any of you
who are familiar with Bill Nye,
The Science Guy, that's a pretty
lovely quote coming from him.
So, what  know really well to take my
own medicine
and answer my own question is "How do you
ask powerful questions to create
conversations
that matter?" And so, what I hope to do
today
is share a couple stats that might blow
your mind.
And then 3 really concrete tools
that you can use to make your
conversations better.
And so the first stat and my question to
you just to ponder is,
"How many questions do you think we ask
per day?"
And let's actually break that down. How
many questions do you think kids
between the ages of 3 and 5 ask
per day? On average kids ask 300 to
400 questions per day. And any of you who
are parents
know this quite well, right? How about
adults?
How many questions do you think adults
ask per day?
6 to 12. 6 to 12
questions per day. And I'm assuming some
of those are "When are you coming home?
And what's for dinner?" And some other
very mundane
things. And so, whoa! What happened?
There's this national
international curiosity gap. Now, I'm not
advocating that we go back to 300 to 400
questions.
But I am going to suggest that if you
want to make really meaningful
connections
that knowing how to ask really great
questions
is a phenomenal tool to help get you
there. And so,
what I want to unpack today is
how do we ask questions? Because think
about
you know when you typically whether it's
virtually or in person, when you meet
another person for the very first time
and you can ask any question you can say,
anything you want. You're meeting this
person for the very first time,
what questions do we typically ask?
How are you? Where are you from?
What do you do?
And even in a room full of a lot of
smart people,
a virtual room full of a lot of smart
people, we tend to only ask one of 3
or 4 questions
when we meet somebody for the first time.
This is interesting, right?
We could ask anything but we tend to ask
one of 3 or 4 very safe questions.
I think the reason for that is that our
brains are wired for that, right? If
you've ever gone to a wedding,
nobody walks into a wedding and says, "Oh,
who do I know
least in the room and can I go sit down
next to them?"
No. Right? We go we... Our default is to say
who do we know most,
what's most comfortable and to gravitate
toward that.
And so, I'm going to invite us as you use
conversation starter throughout the
conference.
And in your conversations moving on
beyond
trend lab. I'm going to invite you to
think about what would happen
if you changed your question count and
you ask 7 questions instead of 6
in a day. What would happen if you
followed your natural
genuine curiosity? So, before I show
these 3 tips,
why? What's the point? Organizationally,
right?
Google is a company that really likes
data, right? It's a company filled with
engineers and very left-brained
folks and they love data. And a few years
ago, they launched this giant research
internal research project to unpack and
uncover what are the characteristics of
the highest performing teams
at google. And the number 1
characteristic that they found was not
the
degree or... It wasn't the level of
technical experience in the group. It
wasn't the
perfect personality Myers-Briggs blend.
The number one characteristic of high
performing teams
at google was the degree of
psychological safety
in that team. Which is really PHD
academic term for interpersonal trust.
"Can I be myself at work? Can I share my
ideas and trust that they'll be.. Even if
people disagree that they get
constructed rather than smashed down?"
And so, I would argue that if we
extrapolate that data a little bit,
that the number one characteristic of
really high performing conversations
really meaningful conversations
is often the degree of psychological
safety in that conversation.
And so, what can you do to create that? So,
ideas that come from uh
my book Ask Powerful Questions Create
Conversations That Matter.
So, if you look the the book and the
tools and what I
my work is structured into this tier. So,
wouldn't it be really convenient
if you could just snap your
fingers
and make the person that you were
meeting with feel like you were willing
to know them, like you saw them, like you
heard them, you got them and you were
ultimately with them. Right? But especially as an engineer, if
you consider yourself
any bit of socially awkward and
conversation is just like
a bit of a slog for you, right? This is
pretty hard to create actually.
And so, flipping it around are a series
of tools that i want to unpack. I want to
give you the first 3
spark notes version. So, the first one is
intention.
Intention is a really interesting word.
And the Latin root the word
intention
actually means to stretch.
Right? And I love that concept. Because I
think an intention is very different
than an
objective in a conversation or then a
mission or a purpose, right?
If you enter a networking conversation
with the objective
to get something from another person,
that person is going to feel like
garbage, right? So, the idea of an
intention and stretching an intention,
yeah, I think a really great intention
stretches
over the needs of everybody in the
conversation and not just you. So, it
serves more than
just your needs. And so, my invitation
or the tool here is in your
conversations, as you're using
conversation starter and
going through your work life, the tool
here is to get clear about your
intention
and share it with the person that it
affects. Now, this is a little bit
unnatural for us because very often, we
have intentions
that might affect other people but very
rarely do we actually
share those intentions with the people
that they affect.
And when we don't do that, that's
actually manipulation. So, when you're in
a networking conversation and you're
wanting to get a deal, you're wanting to
get
some information, you're trying to get
them to do something
that you want without necessarily
telling them. That's manipulation. And so,
my invitation is before you split out
into conversation starter, which by the
way, just
a little digital inception here. So,
conversation starter
is going to look like this. This, I
printed out a web page.
Whoa! And so, find this a little pink
button
wherever your digital spheres are to set
up a profile on conversation starter
so that you can be paired
algorithmically with
the right people to be in conversation
and connection with.
And my invitation is when you get to
those, get clear about what is your
intention
or the way that conversations starter
phrase is. What is your request?
And share that with the person that
affects. Share that with the person that
you're actually talking to.
Tip number 2, one of my absolute
favorite questions.
"What are you curious about right now?"
The most intelligence from the most
intelligent to the least intelligent
human beings on the planet,
people are really good at picking up on
natural genuine curiosity.
So, kids, right? 300 to 400 questions a day
have lots of natural curiosity.
Adults 6 to 12 questions per day.
Somewhere along the line we've lost our
curiosity.
And so, tip number 2 is to follow your
natural genuine curiosity
based on what someone is sharing with
you. And so the best way to trick your
brain into listening really effectively
is to hear what somebody else is saying...
Stop thinking about yourself and all
your experience and how you can relate
to that.
And just think about what are you
curious about
right now? Alright what are you curious
to know about that person
right now? And follow up with a sentence
that
ends in a question mark, not a period. So,
ask a question.
Right? It's somewhere along the line as
adults we learned the pattern of
you speak then I speak. You speak then
I speak.
And it's a really great tool in
conversation to have you speak,
I ask. You speak, I speak, you ask.
Right? To weave in questions throughout.
Cool. So, follow your natural genuine
curiosity based on what you're hearing
somebody say.
The third and final tool that I'll drop
with you today I want to share in the
form of a story. So, If used to work for
this organization
called world and conversation and my job
was to
sit down and have conversation,
facilitate and lead conversations
with strangers from very different
backgrounds about very difficult
topics of conversation. And so my job
was to
break the ice and make that as least
awkward as possible
and create a really meaningful
conversation. So, 90 minutes. Picture a
group of people sitting down in a circle
talking to each other.
Sometimes about race, relations, politics,
long-term conflict.
Things that are not typically discussed
especially with strangers, right?
And so, in order for that conversation to
go well, going back to that google study,
we've got to have a high degree of
psychological safety
in order to make that really work. And so,
I was teaching a bunch of other
facilitators how to do this. And I don't
think you can teach people
how to ask questions without actually
experiencing it. And so, we stopped the
workshop. It was a middle of a 3-hour
workshop. We stopped the workshop
and we said, "You've got 3 minutes to
use the tools we've shared with you
about
getting clear about your intention and
sharing it and following your natural
curiosity to build a relationship of
trust
with 3 strangers. Go." And the room...
Those 20
students in the room were kind of
freaking out. They were not interested in
doing this exercise.
So, I don't believe in asking somebody to
do something i'm not willing to do
myself.
And so, on this particular time, I was
like, "All right. If I've got to do this,
I'm going to run a quick errand." And so, I
head downtown to a convenience store.
I pick out a couple items that I want.
And as I'm checking out, there's a woman
who's has bright colored tattoos
all over her neck. And I'm like "Oh!" I
teach this stuff. I'm going to follow my
natural curiosity. So, I get to the front
and I say, "I'm just so curious.
What's the story behind your tattoos?" And
she goes, "I like the colors."
Oh! Right? Did not build a relationship
with trust.
We get back to the room. All the students
come back, the
energy in the room is electric because
everybody's just had 3 experiences,
successes or failures aiming to build a
relationship a trust. And one student
quiets everybody down he's like, "Whoa! I
have to share this first. We go to
debrief this.
I've got to share this first. I was
ticked
when you asked me to do this. I did not
want to do this." And so I said, "If I have
to do this,
I might as well get something done while
I'm at it. And so i walked down to on the
convenience store.
I picked out a couple items that I
really, really
needed. And I got to the front and
there was a cashier
wearing bright colored tattoos all over
her neck.
And I looked at her and I said,
I'm just curious I have to ask, how
annoying does it get
when people ask you about your tattoos?"
She just starts gushing with information.
And so she starts gushing and she... And
what she says... She specifically said, "Oh, my
gosh. I have no idea. Sometimes I wish I
never got them. I feel like wearing a
turtleneck
in the summer to cover them up. In fact,
there was just this guy in here asking
me,
what's the story behind your tattoos?"
So, my question to you to share the final
the third and final tip with you is
what was the difference between his
success
and my failure? I would argue
that it was empathy. It was in that
moment that she was able to put
at least one of his feet into somebody
else's shoes.
And so, as you dive into your
conversations through conversation
starter, think about
what is somebody else wanting, caring
about needing
and be able to ask follow your natural
curiosity rooted in
empathy for the other person? Because
there's a very powerful shift that
happens
in conversation when we stop thinking
about this person
and we start thinking about the other
person.
I'm Chad Littlefield. It was awesome to
share some time in cyberspace with you.
Go create some conversations that
matter. Have
an awesome day.
Here's a bonus question for you.